das beste kommt erst noch sagte us
präsident donald trump am ende seiner
rede zur lage der nation
nancy pelosi zerreißt da ihre kopie des
textes im anschluss gefragt warum sie
das getan habe sagt die demokratische
oppositionsführerin weil es die höfliche
variante angesichts der alternativen war
es ist das aufsehenerregende ende der
jährlichen ansprache des präsidenten im
kongress in washington
die rede des republikaners trump und die
reaktion der gegenseite machen auf
drastische weise die tiefe politische
spaltung der usa deutlich schon zum
auftakt gibt es deutliche zeichen der
spannung pelosi und mehrere weitere
demokratinnen sind in weiß gekleidet als
zeichen für die gleichberechtigung von
frauen und als kritik an jump jump
wiederum verweigert pelosi vor beginn
seiner rede einen handschlag er bricht
damit mit einer tradition in der rede
selbst rührt trump seine politik der
vergangenen jahre
die arbeitslosenrate sei auf dem
niedrigsten stand seit mehr als einem
halben jahrhundert die einkommen wuchsen
die armut sinke die kriminalität gehe
zurück die usa würden international
wieder respektiert republikanischen
senatoren und abgeordneten quittieren
die rede immer wieder mit applaus und
erheben sich von ihren sitzen die
demokraten dagegen verfolgen die rede
mit versteinerten mienen manche
äußerungen kritieren sie mit
kopfschütteln
mehrere abgeordnete verlassen den saal
trump hält die rede am vorabend der
abstimmung im us-senat über seine
amtsenthebung die demokraten werfen ihm
in der ukraine affäre amtsmissbrauch und
behinderung des kongresses vor eine
amtsenthebung gilt allerdings als
ausgeschlossen denn james republikaner
haben im senat die mehrheit und sie
stehen fest hinter dem präsidenten
zudem stiegen zuletzt in umfragen die
zustimmungswerte für trump